Jonathan, I got one more question for you.
You know what this is?
You mentioned our very own Twitter ding dong previously.
You've had another ding dong overnight, I believe,
this time with one Gary. Lennica,
can you just give us
your thoughts about what he said about you on Twitter?
Well, I think Margaret Thatcher said it best in the past,
which may be like Sakir Stahmer,
Gary Linnekull become a fan of,
which is that if they can't debate with you politically,
they start to insult you personally.
I do actually think there's a potential breach here
of the social media guidelines
that Gary Lineker has signed up to,
which says that individual politicians
should not be insulted personally.
And sadly Gary Lineker decided to do that.
So I have written to Tim Davy,
the director general of the BBC
to look into this.
Uh, and as I say,
well, I'll wait back for his feedback.
This is very sad that these so called celebrities,
the wo karate,
the elites of this country
seem to think they understand that
how to govern the country.
If Gary Lynnick is so confident
he could do such a great job,
why not stand and run for Parliament?
He's very welcome to run against me
in Stoke on trend north.